[Música]
quem é você
toda vez que um paciente meu novo chega
no meu consultório e sempre no divã eu
faço essa pergunta pra ele ea resposta a
essa pergunta faz com que ele entre em
análise tem como a gente chama ela no
meio que se coloca é analítico e você
você já fez essa pergunta você é o
momento da sua vida
quem é você e essa resposta você obteve
olhando pra dentro desse olho na sua
volta através do outro
particularmente é eu ando me
questionando muito com relação a essa
minha nova identidade né
é eu sou mãe né recém mamãe há sete
meses e tinham a uma imagem muito bem
definida profissional mas estou
desenvolvendo uma nova imagem é agora
como mãe é essa nossa imagem como mãe
de certa forma ela está sendo muito
ajudado pela imagem profissional é
psicóloga que também né tem duas coisas
bem o mundo né
é então ser psicóloga quanto ser mãe eu
tenho como função cuidar do outro mas em
compensação tem uma diferença importante
é o meu filho e outros são os meus
pacientes como se a isso
eu lembro que quando eu pensei em ser
mãe é eu fui questionado galera se vai
mesmo ser mãe é sua profissão seja tão
né e certa como psicóloga já renomada
tal se vai mesmo arriscar isso e eu
muito tempo disse que não é não vou
arriscar vou continuar sob se colocam
até que surgiu aquela vontade depois de
15 anos de relação
vendo não eu acho que você não ensina e
aí eu mudei consultório nessa saída de
um centro de saúde que era o hospital
não teria condições de levar meu filho
com três meses porque sim eu quero
trabalhar depois de três meses de um
filho nascido e aí eu pensei eu vou
fazer um outro consultório é uma casa e
eu coloquei ao lado do meu consultório
essa linha e comecei a gravar meu filho
depois que o clube já completou três
meses comigo sempre comigo para
amamentar e cuidar do paciente voltar a
cuidar do meu filho na escolinha cuidar
do paciente é considerado até hoje dessa
maneira como eu consegui são porque eu
tenho auto imagem bem definida e
positiva profissional e isso me deu
força pra pesada
as críticas às outras pessoas me
questionando o que eu ia voltar cedo é o
trabalho e deixar meu filho com dois
meses e porque eu não ia cuidar é
especificamente somente dos nossos
pacientes também têm que conciliar o
filha e eu fui e conseguir aquilo que a
gente provou isso pra vocês
e aí eu pergunto vocês
como formamos a nossa autoimagem eu vou
dar um exemplo pra vocês pra vocês
entenderem isso imaginem marinho e joão
é duas crianças que têm a mesma
funcionária ambas
adoro ler livros são mais introspectivos
e ficam mais tempo é entre os seus
quartos nem os seus livros
só que eles têm é como diferença mas
completamente diferentes
a maria é filho de pais mais esportistas
que valorizam de graças ao ar livre
já o joão é filho de pais mais
intelectuais que valoriza mais tempo com
a família e que dentro de casa e quando
a maioria dentro do quarto
os pais de maria reclama com ela porque
ela está dentro do quarto
fazendo coro com esportes ela riu outras
crianças
já os pais de um elogio ele quando ele
está no quarto livro pergunta vocês quem
tem uma imagem uma imagem mais positiva
joão bahia
exatamente porque o jogo ainda foi
reforçada com relação a isso e aí a
questão da nossa formação da imagem
inicialmente a gente forma na sua imagem
pela maneira como os outros longe não é
algo que vem da gente é o que vem do
outro e aí esses rótulos têm a tendência
de fazer com que a gente encare a vida
de uma certa maneira se você tem
objetivos que você tem com
consequentemente uma imagem positiva
você vai ter a sua bíblia porque você
vai ser capaz de fazer coisas novas a
partir de experiências novas coisas e os
projetos enfim os objetivos já se você
tiver uma imagem negativa ou seja os
negativos
você não vai ter sucesso na sua vida
porque você não vai ser capaz
você vai tentar fazer coisas novas
e aí gente
a nossa imagem ele é um contacto pessoal
social e cultural é um exemplo pra vocês
um impacto cultural disso
[Música]
um aspecto meramente biológico
foi algo muito legal e para responder
isso
ela fez uma pesquisa em três trios é
meninas e publicou em 1935 um livro
chamado o site vem para 83 sociedades
primitivas interessante que ela
descobriu esse estudo dela que não não é
biológico também já existisse isso é
brincadeira de meninos e brincadeira
minha não é lógico é cultural
na primeira tribo ela viu que ambos os
sexos masculino e feminino eles tinham o
mesmo temperamento
eles eram mais pacíficos
já a segunda trigo é um pouco é uma
noite diferente eles eram mais
guerreiros atitude mais guerreira
as mulheres já têm seu trio que essa foi
a mais interessante
efe ambos eram conhecidos na época
atualmente são conhecidas com sandri
eles fizeram o seguinte comportamento
ela pela imagem que os homens são os que
se enfeitam eles enfeitam né
eles que cuidam dos filhos ele se cuida
dos afazeres domésticos não são as
mulheres as mulheres elas vão à caça que
todo entorno para que os homens possam
cuidar da família
e olha que foi descoberto em 1935
a mulher e quanto ao papel social
feminino e masculino de vocês foi de
fato ao formado por você já parou para
pensar nisso
então o exercício que eu quero que vocês
façam a partir de hoje é que vocês
pensem melhor como elas são as suas
identidades
quem é você como homem quem é você como
mulher como cidadão como filho e aí você
se questionando isso você vai entender a
importância de você entender nossas
identidades dos açudes para suas
diferenças para sociais em seus
diferentes em touros e isso é importante
para você se sentir mais plano mais
seguro e os demais em sua vida também
como é que você pode fazer isso como é
que você pode descobrir seus mercados
pode de repente é escolher um ano
sabático que você decidiu fazer as
coisas pensando em você é ele tem que
mandar aquele emprego que você não gosta
mais o relacionamento não faz mais feliz
em conhecer lugares diferentes
você pode fazer uma viagem incrível na
europa o chicão ou américa do sul
ou então de repente simplesmente
conhecer um novo restaurante que tem na
cidade mas fazer coisas diferentes
você pode descobrir os prazeres de um
livro é interessante família ou de
repente ouviu michael filho e um muito
legal ou uma música toca você
você mais emocionado mas eu não sei nem
escolher aquelas ao lado sabia que você
diga lá pronto socorro por algumas horas
é e fica conectado em você e ele
descobriu os pequenos mais exercê los ou
se permitir começar a falar não os
exercícios também pra você não é o outro
mas você ou fazer algo novo como eu
parecia um filho mas só será menos
dramático por exemplo conta a água que
eu escrever um livro sobre ela disse
cleto ou sei lá fazer um novo curso de
língua é mais fazer uma coisa diferente
que você nunca fez na família ou fazer
psicoterapia gente é importante também
para você se conhecer
então não existe uma receita pronta
não existe o que existe é a vontade de
você querer conhecer você buscar isso
e atrás e finalmente no rn nas suas
diferenças sociais e descobrir quem é
você
obrigado
[Aplausos]